[Music]
with Christmas just around the corner
Netflix have decided to release their
own festive film to celebrate the
holiday starring Kurt Russell throughout
this video I'll be discussing everything
you need to know about the film as well
as its surprise cameo at the end there
will be heavy spoilers Sofia yet seen a
film that I highly suggest that you turn
off now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to buy the film's midpoint Santa
has been arrested and it's up to his to
stowaways Teddy and Kate to save the day
Teddy and Kate joined by Santa's elves
that live in his sack look up trying to
avoid as many sack jokes as possible and
which is a bit like the TARDIS as it's
bigger on the inside
spring the Christmas character from the
prison and return him his hat Santa's
hat is the source of his powers and it
allows him to turn into coal and escape
the prison but with just an hour left
until sunrise the group have to come up
with a clever way to deliver presents
quickly basically a say clever it sort
of just involves them throwing things
out the Slayer high speed whilst they
drive along hopefully my weights bench
didn't hit anyone on the way down as I
can't be bothered with the hassle after
asking for a gun for Christmas last year
Santa almost misses a child in Mexico
because hey tension isn't high enough
already between the US and the country
but he manages to do this and saves the
day Santa drops Teddy and Kate off at
their home and reveals that he never
really needed the hat to fly which could
imply that he's just a complete
psychopath not like stressing out kids
or it could also in fact imply that he
created the whole ordeal so that he
could just bring a little magic to their
lives
anyway Santa steals the camcorder
footage of the night so that should
Teddy or Kate tell anyone about it they
would seem crazy be sent to an insane
asylum and live out the rest of their
lives climbing up the wall and eating
their own vomit
Santa returns to the North Pole to give
a surprise cameo his own Pole and we
learn that he actually comes more than
once a year
when we see that his wife is played by
real-life wife of Kurt Russell Goldie
Hawn I wonder how she got the job in
this film
anyway mrs. Claus suggests that they
watch a Christmasy movie like It's a
Wonderful Life
or the Grinch however Santa picks up the
tape from Kate's camcorder and says that
he had something else in mind something
really cool this implies that the film
is the same no actually no it's better
than those movies and that we should
keep paying our netflix subscription or
be damned to a life of unhappiness so
yep kind of scraping the barrel a bit
with these index playing videos for this
one but it was an okay movie wasn't it
it's a kids movie anyway so yeah it's
fine I don't know why you hate it so
much you buddy adult it's not for you
but tell me what your thoughts on the
Christmas Chronicles are and if you
enjoyed the movie comment below and let
me know what you hope to get for
Christmas this year I can't really tell
Santa for you but maybe he will read the
YouTube comments and you will get that
scale actrix that you've always dreamed
of if you like this video then like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of this week's episode of The Walking
Dead which will be linked at the end of
this one I know these two aren't really
related but you know I've got a spam my
own links a bit this is a channel for
people who were made into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'm sorry for
annoying of this video but I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you